皆さんこんにちは日本柔らかく協会の会長
の柳井と申しますよろしくお願いいたし
ます今日はありがとうございますNHKの
スイッチインタビューは2回に当たりまし
て
先生と小倉智昭さんの
対談が放送されましたそれで
こちらに足を運びいただいた方もいるので
はないかなと思います私も
いろいろデータ社の人たちがいてですね
カメラ回したり
司会をやったりしてるんですけどあるいは
受付とかですねあるいは告知とかみんなの
ボランティアでやってますとても私も
活動に関わるまではもらったりでやると
いう機会がなかったんですけど本当にお
寺というか仏教のお手伝いをするって
とても
楽しくてですねやりがいがあります
ちょっと普通のボランティアともちょっと
こう手応え感が違うのかなと思うのでぜひ
皆さん体験していただけたらなと思います
それで一番
代表的な
お手伝いと言いますかお店ボランティアが
ですね私どもにとってはお布施であると
思いますそれ前回のテーマでもあったん
ですけれどもお坊様にお見せするとですね
とても気持ちが何て言うんでしょう喜びが
もう本当
にすごく大きいんです
よね私がよく覚えてるのは今回
司会していただいてる
佐藤哲郎さんが一時中継なさったことが
あったんですけどその時新米のまっさらな
佐藤さん
成田さんっておっしゃったんですけどにお
布施させていただいてその時友達と2人
だったんですけどお店させていただく
補正させていただいた時の喜びがまだ
なんか
どうか心に残ってる気がするんですよね
本当に
お見せさせたいただいた時の喜びって
とても大きいのでぜひ皆さんに体験して
いただきたいと思い
ますで4月の121日がお休みでござい
ますけども
ちょうど皆さんで
お食事のお店をオープンにしたい方どうぞ
ということで声がかかっておりますので
手ぶらでもぜひお越しいただければと思い
ますもし何か一品なんか少しでもっていう
ことでしたら本当に一人分2人でもいいの
で
果物でも何でもご飯あるいはお花とかでも
結構だと思うんですけどお持ちいただいて
もよろしいかと思いますその場合は9時に
ですね9時10時ぐらいかなお布施自体は
11時ぐらいに始まりますので
にお越しいただけたらと思います幡ヶ谷の
ですね大谷翔平でございます
目の前が
旗が6頭でございましてちょうどこの間
桜が開花宣言がありまして今今日見てき
たらまだちらほらでしたけど
これから雨が
上がって暖かくなってくるので見頃になる
のかなと
期待してます今
菩提寺さんもございましてですね整備した
のでとても美しいですねちょっと寒さに
やられた葉っぱが落ちてしまったんです
けどもとても
前で
参拝させていただくとですね本当にまあ
ちょっと心が洗われるような気持ちになり
ますのでぜひお参りいただければと思い
ますそして5月に入りますと大阪の大月で
ございまして5月のですね13日には
こちらで
ベース火災がございますそちらご案内が
またメールとかですねあるいはホーム
ページとかでございますのでぜひぜひ皆
さんお越しいただければと思いますで5月
の14日は魚民庁舎でお食事の世界ですね
オフ式がございます
諸々最新の情報は
ホームページの方でアップされております
のでご覧ください今日のこの後ですね8時
今夜ですね
ズーム交流会ございますけどちょっと佐藤
さんに先生に使ったスライドをお借りして
それを見ながら
復習しがてら
皆さんにとの交流を
高められたらと思ってますそれは
メールで皆さん
告知の方でご案内
申し込まれた方にメールでご案内してます
のでそれご確認くださいもしなければ受付
の方に紙がありますのでお伝えいただけれ
ばと思います以上ですちょっと長くなり
ました失礼いたしますよろしくお願い
いたします
[拍手]
はいありがとうございますでは間もなく
開会いたしますのでそのままお待ち
ください
[音楽]
食べる前に
しかたがん様に
[音楽]
様に
あげ
られるまに
しかばん
さまで
[音楽]
そばに
加盟すみちゃんまで
[音楽]
[笑い]
仕方
がん様に
[音楽]
あなたに
紹介します
私は
[音楽]
幸せでありますよう
に私の
悩み苦しみが
なくなりますように
私の
願い事が
叶える
[音楽]
私に
悟りの光
[音楽]
が
現れますよう
[音楽]
に私は
幸せであります
ように
私は
幸せになります
[音楽]
私は
幸せであります
私は幸せでありますように繰り返し心の中
で念じます
私が
親しいぜ
[音楽]
幸せでありますよう
に私の
親しい生命の
苦しみが
なくなりますね
私の
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられますね
私が
親しい
生命に
悟りの光が
現れません
私の
[音楽]
幸せであります
ように
私が
親しい生命
が
幸せでありますね
私が
汗だく自然
にみんな
幸せであります
[音楽]
しかし生命が幸せでありますように
繰り返し念じます
[笑い]
[音楽]
ように
行けたしに行けるもの
悩み苦しみが
なくなります
ように
息苦しいに行けるもの
[音楽]
願い事が
叶えられます
ように
生きとしみけるもの
に
悟りの光が
現れます
行けたしに行けるものが
[音楽]
幸せであります
生きとしに行けるものが
幸せでありますね
[音楽]
息がしみけるものが
幸せであります
ように
息吹しに行けるもの
で
あります
ように生きたし行けるものが
[音楽]
幸せであります
はいありがとうございます
ではよろしくお願いします
天気が悪くなりました
本当に
頂きましてありがとうございます
今日は
仏像の
ステーキで
第一ステージである道徳というところ
について説明したいと思います
道徳倫理と言ったらこの世間で言っている
ようなレベルでないということは理解
できると思います
だいたい
仏教と他の世の中にある様々の教え全て
まとめたら
仏教はどこら辺違いますかと
理解したい場合は一番簡単な
はい入口はこの道徳を理解すれば
ね分かると思いますねなぜか
悪いことするなよとかね
嘘つくなよとかね誰だって知っていること
だからねでは
そこら辺ねどんな宗教でもねそんなことは
言っているし
ね人のもの取るなよとか
ねそんなもんかと
人から何かパクって喋っているんでしょう
かとかねだからお釈迦様がこの
悟って自ら発見して
未だかして世の人々は知らなかった真理を
語っているんですそれは道徳みたいな誰に
だって理解
ところから
比較してみると何かわかるでしょうと思い
ます
説法会のお布施はね前田真理子様ですね
それからまあ教会のさんならね
息子さんからねまたいろいろな方々が
スタッフの方々大変いろいろ準備をして
苦労してその教員
説法か生きるんで講演会で何ですか今日は
七宝界でも講演会どちらでもないです
それを実現できましたこと皆様に心から
感謝いたしますありがとうございます皆様
方幸福でありますようにと世界致します
はい
そこでまぁ道徳でしょうちょっと厳しい
態度取らなくちゃあかんだからね法律
みたいなことでね
日本のことよくわからんだけど法律作る時
でも
憲法学ではチャプター1日123とかね
そうやってセクションごとに書くんですね
まあ言うかの有名な
樹海に合わせて
シャッター10にしようかなと思ったん
です
これはちょっとした遊びですけどね
で
いわゆるこの憲法の
スタート
イントロダクションですね
で道徳という前に
命って何かと理解しなくちゃ
いけないだから命の構成
それぞれ知った上でどう生きるのかという
ことが見えてくるんですね
そこで
まず一般的に理解できる説明始まります
命は様々な組織でできている
複合体です
ね私で言ったっても
複合体なん
ですで皆様の知識世間的な知識から見れば
目は目なりの組織ですね
自分でいろんなことをやって頑張っている
んですね
耳は耳鳴りの
組織で目とシステムが違います
決して耳はねちょっと
困ったんだけどどうすればいいかと目に
相談しません
耳にトラブルあっても目にトラブルがあっ
ても
相談しません
胃袋やらそこはそれぞれの
働きシステムがあります
でその中で筋肉は筋肉の仕事ある場合は
組織はそちらのシステムがあるのは
脳みそは脳みそのシステムがあるそれは
学校でも学んだら分かりますね例えば
脳みそというのは
各システムに電気
信号を送ってオンオフやってもらえますね
スピードを下げるか上げるか
やっているんですね
それから
脳みそで
それぞれ
組織に必要な時々この物質があるんですね
働くために
言いますけどねそれを送ってあげるんです
ねそれで
乾燥に必要なホルモンが
腎臓に行っても意味がないん
ですでそこら辺は一応自分の
ものだけ受け取ってくる見事に仕事をして
います
心臓組織はそれはそれで頑張っているし
それ
循環組織は一番仕事をしていますね
欠席は
そういうことでこの
身体の表記は
それぞれ自由で仕事をしているん
です
耳は耳の世界目は目の世界
胃袋は胃袋の世界
乾燥は乾燥の世界で工場みたいな感じで
あっちまで仕事しているんです
だから出て好き勝手にわがままでもないん
ですね他の
葬儀の調子もどうでしょうかと
チェックしながら
まあ動いてますねまぁ今日黒田さんがこの
肉体車で運んでくれたんだけど雨が降って
いるんですねそうすると
車の交通状態はそれによっていくらか管理
されます
ね別に雨がねあなた方は気をつけて運転し
なさいもうちょっとスピード下げます言っ
てないん
ですあれは降るだけで
やっぱりそこで
合わせるんでしょう
だから
胃腸がちょっと調子が悪くなってくると他
のところもやっぱり
心配だなとか思っちゃいますよ
そこでこの心というものもあるんですね
それは物体じゃないんです
ね
脳みそでもないんです
で心も勝手に仕事をしているんだけど
しかし
肉体
隠す大きいの
状況も見ながら
そちらの影響を受けながら
謝る
調整しながら心は
活動しているんですね
ですからこのいろんな生命
組織
複合体
お互いに連絡しやって
ある程度で自立して
しかし連絡しなくちゃいけない
[音楽]
その中で
親分は見つからないんです
ね
タイの中
で誰も及ぶんですか
一つでもなくなっちゃうとシステムが
壊れるん
ですこれ気が普通の機械車と同じなんです
よ一つ外しちゃうともう車でなくなっ
ちゃうん
ですただタイヤ外しちゃったらもうどう
動かないんでしょう
だからでタイヤが車ということでもないん
ですねそこで理解して欲しいのは
我々は私私私とかすごく威張っているんだ
けど
それがどこにあるのか
どこにもないん
ですけどおかしくなるのは
探せば見つからない
探しても見つからない私という観念が
ね
全部支配管理しようとするんです
ねそこで道徳っていうのは
至ってシンプルこれやめなさい
おかしくなります
心臓が
描く臓器に指令するならば心臓が実際に
あるんだから
いくらか仕方がないと思ってもいいんだ
けど
審査はそんな
条件なことはしません
ひたすら自分の仕事
控えめで
頑張って
ますで欠席が私が一番大事な仕事をしてい
ますよ
運搬役だからね
ちょうどシステムなかったら
終わりだから欠席だけは全ての臓器と
コネクションがあります
よでも
欠席はそんなこと思ってないんですね
私が全部管理しますよと
はい次行きます
それから行動管理
この身体の
ファンクションの管理すること
道徳です
管理しなかったら
心と
他の組織が
互いに調整して
活動するために他人の管理は道徳的な生き
方になります
だから心が勝手に
字が張って暴走しちゃうと
他の臓器システムには迷惑なんですね
あれはあったら
気分屋でその手が働きますその時
椅子とやりますとか
ねこれでうまくいかない
だから全てのファンクションをうまく
活動させるための
管理
それが道徳ということです
ね
それがなくなると
コントロールは嫌だと言ったってもどうし
ても必要でしょう
それで時々ありますよ
感想が
調和してやりたいんだけどなんか異常
が起きちゃって別に行動する
調和が
崩れちゃうんですね
腎臓の時々そうなったり
胃袋もそうなったり
心臓はそうなったりする大変でしょうし
ねそういうのはそこにいる病気なんですね
それはその
臓器を何とか手入れしていろいろ何とか
すれば
治ったりあるいはもう
修理それほどできないとかどちらかですね
それでこの心とのファンクションが
乱れたら
暴走すると
大変なことになります
身体の
葬儀が
異常行動を起こすん
ですそれで心ということが皆様何なのか今
の物理学的な説明で分からないかもしれ
ませんだけどこの感覚ですねお互いに
感じるという
ねそこをちょっと
乱れたら感覚は行かなかったら
その臓器が知ります
変な感覚で言ったらすごく異常行動を
起こします
ねですから
物質的な体は大体自然法則だから
そこまで
管理しなくてだいたいうまくいくん
ですそれは我々は
植えたら水をあげてまぁ別に24時間
見張っていなくたっても大丈夫です
たまたまどうなっているのかとか後ろも
入っているのかとかね
チェックするだけで十分
ですだから身体のメンテナンスはすごい
簡単です
証拠で心はそうじゃないんです
ね心がとにかく
暴走したい
いい加減なことをしたいという感じで
働いてもハチャメチャなんです
全部おかしくなるんですそれでも気にし
ない
だから
心が落ち着いて
仕事するようにと
コントロールするんでしょう
だからそれが
道徳ということに定義するんですだから
道徳ないと
命が成り立たないん
ですマネージメント
校の場合は流れるのと感謝します
感謝しますすることが道徳でそれやらない
と全部細胞組織が
おかしくなってお互いにある
総合性というかねそれがなくなっちゃって
大変なことになりますそこで誰かが
マネジメントを観察しますという道徳
西洋で考えた
哲学者の
妄想やと思っているでしょうだからあまり
来なくじゃない人が
ね関係ないやとも思ったりするんだけど
そうじゃないんですよ
そうすると
身体の臓器はみんな
問題なく
順調に
活動するんですその結果すごく
幸せになります
そこで
身体にも
使用期限がありますから物質だから
だから使用期限
終わるまで体が
活動してくれます要するに
寿命を全うすることができます
世の中でほとんど人々は
寿命を全うしないん
全うする前に心臓発作を起こしたり
あるいは
出血してね何とかなったり
癌になったり
色々します
が癌組織そのものを見ても
あれは
異常組織ですね
細胞たちがなんかみんなと調和してでは
なくて俺が自分勝手に
泣くとやるんだよと
あの家に住んでいる言うこと聞かない子供
みたいな感じで本人が自分好きなことやっ
ていて
親が言うこと聞かないから
そんな感じになるんですね
はい
それで分かるんですこの道徳っていうのは
何か変な
宗教的なあるいは哲学的な私たちに関係
ないではないんですね
これは
どう生きるのかというすごい
現実的な
ものすごく必要な決して無視できない
ことなんです
言葉変えると呼吸と同じ大事なんです道徳
は
呼吸なんかただ
汚れている空気でしょう
吸わないとかね
そんな
我儘はできませんねやっぱり空気を吸わ
なくちゃいけない
それやめたら直ちに
組織壊れて
それと同じで道徳も
ね24時間
心の管理しなくちゃいかんです
そこで道徳
憲法のシャッター位置が終わりまして
シャッターに入ります
テーマはわかるでしょう
説明したんですよ
でチャプター2で
もっとが発見した12個の一般的に誰にで
もわかること言ったんです
そこでお釈迦様が発見した
ところ
を説明します
お釈迦様は命は
幸運で構成されていると言うんですね
ご存じでしょうね
音というのは組織
これで一番目は指揮運と言うん
ですここで色と書いてありますけどこれは
物質という意味なんです
あれは細胞にしてもいいんです細胞
組織全てまとめて
1個にしたん
あんまり心臓は
肝臓は
腎臓とかないん
ですそれはお釈迦様の
分かりやすくするためのどちらが一番大事
なのかというためにした分析なんですね
学校に行ったらもう細胞を一個一個学ぶか
組織ごとに学ぶかもう
専門的に
医療は医学学ぶと心臓のプロになれば肝臓
のプロになるか
ね消化器官のプロになるかあれやこれやと
か
眼科にいろいろ
そんなに大げさですか
すごいお金かけてすごい
財産使ってすごい時間をかけて
やる必要あるのかと何もしなくたっても人
は入れてますよ
だから
仏教から見るように人間やっている
我々はこれやとか美容室からねスポーツ
センターとか
それからマンモス病院とか
ね必要ですか
だってどれまでねもう1キロであれは
500m単位で病院があったからといって
どんな医者の人の病気を治すことはでき
ない
ただあらゆる機械でデータ取ってデータ
取ってこれこれこれですと言うだけで
ですからこの
仏教のなってくると資金
そこで本当に道徳だから色
温度は言わないんで
四季
でしたっけ
出家の執着
も
率直でした
執着という意味で
執着
執着という意味で資金
だから
5分ではなくて
募集
あの
執着というところで大事な言葉
それだけやるなよと全て
壊れますよ
すべてを
乱れてしまい
ましょうだから好き集音と言えば
もう
病気で
執着の
執着のそこを何とかしなくちゃ
今説明に私はこの主という単語を入れて
ないん
ですそこで細胞組織全て
仏教では
四季運んで
終わって
ます残りどうなりますよ重層
凝視
10っていうのは
いろんなものを体に触れるでしょう
触れることを受ける
反応する
それ以外に命ですよ
そう感覚ですね感じるんです
ですから
スーパーで買った
ね資金は細胞組織ですけど
命でありません
だって何も感じないんですね
触ってもそちら反応しない
冷凍しても向こうは反応しない
油で揚げても
物理的な変化を起こるだけで
嫌だとは言わないね
でも私たちは何か触れるとすぐ感じるん
ですね
それは
十分
残念ながら
[音楽]
ですそこで道徳が必要になったかの執着も
主があるんだからこれ何とかしなさい
それで
まぁ
騒音っていうのはいろんな概念作ったり
することで
思考とほとんど寝てますね
で常温っていうのはとにかく何とかやり
たいやりたいやりたいというこの衝動的な
働きがあってそれから地球運転の認識
する
ですからこちら4つのファンクション機能
があります
これまとめて
心というんですね
この4音は一体として
活動するん
この4分離れる話すことできない
だから何か感じた瞬間例えば自分の手自分
の指でタッチする
タッチした瞬間で自分も騒音も
業務も支給も起きているん
です4ついつでも一つで働くん
ですでこれは明確に別々なものであると
いう説かれてますからこれはいつでも
証拠に基づいて説明することでどんな人間
にも至って簡単な実験で4つバラバラ別々
なエネルギーだと分かることはできます
それには
すごい金が来る実験室は要りません
体の管理は
十分
騒音
意識運が行っているのです
死音が正しく働くための
注意が
道徳だと
定義できます
仏教的には
道徳とは重曹
業式
の
執着もするところそれは
間違って
命を壊すんでしょう執着が
あれ危険なもの
あの原発と同じで
電気が出てくるのありがたいんだけど
美しい
放射持っているんです
だから
原発を作る場合はもうハチャメチャ何に気
をつけているのかと言うと
風車の問題
一家なる場合でも
放射が漏れないよう
にだからすごい金かかるんですよ
燃やしちゃえば簡単な
の
膨大な生まれます
よそれで今は水を
温めてそれで多分
回転させますけど
将来的に
そのもの電気エネルギーに入れ替えると
入れ替えられる何か
システム開発すれば
水がなくても
できるかもしれませんし
あれはずっと冷やさなくちゃいけないしね
原子炉
地球の物質に耐えられないぐらい
熱が出ます
だから冷やさなくちゃいけないそこは
そんならしくないんだけど
あの水にも放射
能があるし
だからそこは外にバレないように外に
漏れないように
それがだから
原発作る時の苦労の90%その頃な
あらゆる管理システムがあって
警報システムがあって
大変です
かなり大きな土地まで取っちゃって
一般人が
許可なしに迂闊に入るなよとかねそこまで
コントロールして
だからこの
式を
創業式ですね
命でしょう
そちらで5
種類と言うんだから
執着の主に
これを制御しなくちゃ
なんでないと
管理していない
原子炉を見たい
まぁ別にどこかバイトしている人を頼んで
ちょっとあんた
原子力発電所で仕事してくれません
これは
こういう調子いいだけでそれでは大変
でしょう
干したい放題ボタンを押したりとか
原子炉を除いてみたりとか
冗談じゃない
その感じ
で
ブッダから見れば道徳とはこの
執着の主ということ一番
危険なものでそれをコントロールしようと
だから
4分が正しく働くためない注意が道徳だと
定義できます要するに
法則に従って正しく
命を管理することが道徳です
認識の指導で生きる生命には道徳が不可欠
です
そこでちょっとした難しいポイントが出て
いきます
認識の指導で生きていること
我々は
考えて行動するん
ですよ
皆さんは考えて行動しているでしょう
考えて何かやったら
やってはいけないことやってる
ん
ですだから世の中変化
でしょうみんな考えてやってます
よ戦争もハチャメチャ考えた結果でしょう
喧嘩するのもね
考えた上の結論でしょうはい喧嘩します
そちらでこの
認識して行動するんだから
そこら辺で制御しなさい
それで一部の生命がいるんです何も考え
いわゆる本能で生きている
だからこれやってはいけないこれやり
なさいということはあまり関係ない例えば
チンパンジーでも猿でも
犬猫でも
何かくれぐれダメでしょうと言っても別に
という感じでいるでしょう
嘘少ないよと言ったっても
犬に関係ないん
ですだから
認識して感謝しますを使って生きているの
は人間ですね
だから人間には道徳は不可欠です
プレイに入ります
本能いわゆるイカす力
何で生きているのか
とみんな本能を持っているでしょうすべて
の生命は
本能っていうのは生かす力
命を
いくらひどくても活かしちゃう
どんなひどい目にあっても生きていたいと
怒っちゃう
それは仏教用語で割愛と言うんですね
分かりやすく言えば生きていきたいという
本能ですね
本能だけで生きる生命には道徳管理でき
ません
で割愛だけ考えることはしない
認識あるんだけど
認識して
生きることはしない
動物は獲物を見たらパクッと取っちゃう
動くもの見ると
動くもの見ただけで飛んでそこに
叩いたりする
本能です
本能だけだったらまぁ道徳
を入れるところはない
従って生命に成長することもできない
でも動物は道徳はおかしいませんよ面白い
こと
猿チンパンジーは嘘をつきません人を騙し
ません
本能で生きているん
ですするとかなり
威嚇して攻撃します
だから触るなよ
認識
判断をベースにして生きている人間に道徳
が必要です生き方が正しいか否かを
判断して行動するん
我々人間が
この
判断は
間違う可能性がありますから
ね私たち一人一人これが正しいんだから
やりますと
これは食べるものだから食べますと判断
するんです
でもその判断間違ったということはいくら
でもあり得るよく見ると今まで
歴史を人間の歴史考えるとみんな考えて
判断しているんだけど
歴史では
正しいことをやった形式はないん
です人類の歴史はハチャメチャの歴史
でしょう
時々すごい文明があったり
があったりとか
ねわずかな時間で壊れる
持ちませんね日本にもいろんな時代がある
んですね
縄文時代から
何でああいうのは壊れるのか
[音楽]
ですから
判断でしょう
例えばある文化が
繁栄しているのに
隣の
民族が来て
攻撃してこれは潰しちゃう
それでその文化がそれで終わり
で戦争がなくても
古いものは関係ない新しいものにしようと
か
ね新しいものを作るでしょう
それが正しいに判断だったら
いいんだけど次の世界は何でこんな古い
ものでそれは壊して新しいものを作ると
いうことは
判断は
正しくない
ね例えば私たちの年齢でいいことだと思っ
たことは今の若い人々は
古い時代遅れと思っちゃうん
です
職問題なんですねだから一人一人が
自分の
判断
が正しい判断しなくちゃいけない正しい
判断するための
条件サポートが道徳世界な
んです
貼るので道徳他人から
経験者から
理性あるいは知恵がある人から学ぶべき
です
だからこれとても
髪型どうするのかとかね5年前の髪型今
ダサい気持ち悪いとかね5年前のズボンの
あるいはエスカートの下には嫌であればと
そんなのもう何の価値もない
生き方でしょうそんなものばかりで命
抱えるんですかねだから気づかない
よ人間としての命としての
重さが感じていないん
ですエスカートの形どうするのか長さどう
するのかとかいろいろするのか
とそれでもう1年2年プールは
古くてダサいなさいと変なこと言ったりし
て
だから
結局は本能で生きている生き物たちよりも
レベル低い生き方人間やってます
ですから
命ということをよく真剣に考えて正しく
生きる
どうやって正しい方判断するのかというと
我々は誰かから学ばなくちゃいけなくなり
ます
なぜかというとそれにしゃべる方に行き
ますが
[音楽]
ここでこの学ぶ必要があるということに
なります
ね
学ぶの嫌だとかね言ってる場合じゃないん
でしょう
生きていきたいというのはすごいこの本能
が乱れているというテーマでちょっと
アイデア変えます
しかし生かしてくれる
条件ではなく
命に
危うい条件だけが溢れてい
ますこれは誰にでも同じことです誰だって
どんな生命も生きていきたい
本能はそれですそれ仏教用語で形は言って
いるんです
でも生きていきたいなと思って周りを見る
と
怒ってくれない条件ばっかり
自分の命を
壊す条件ばっかり
です例えば
何か食べなくちゃあかんでしょう食べると
我々は大体植物たちが作ったエネルギーを
頂いているでしょう
植物はたくさんあるんだけど数えられない
くらい
でも食べられるものはほんのわずか
自分の指で数えられる
そこで
命を危う状態にする
条件がいっぱいありますね道路に
至っても
殺される原因いくらでもあり
ます
守る条件は少ないんですそれで
我々は
選択しなくちゃいかんですね
危ういものに対してここで問題来るん
です
恐怖感を感じる
んです
生かしてくれる現象にに愛着を抱きし
ますこれで人生の運転が間違えます
まあ
危険なものは当然
溢れています
よでも
恐怖感を抱いちゃうと
怖い怖い怖いばっかしできていられない
でしょう
命を支えてくれるものにあー
好き好き好き好きとかね愛着生きていられ
ないでしょうだから
恐怖感を抱くことも愛着を抱くことも
アウト
そこがやめて欲しいと
さらに現象に対してそこで我々はまた
間違ったことをするんです1取る
獲得する
という態度とに
避ける
捨てる
壊す
攻撃する
という態度
マイナスの二つの態度を作るんですね人間
が
取るか壊すかでしょう
よく怒りなどの感情が行動を管理すること
になりますそれから人の生き方は
欲が管理する
怒りが管理する
欲があんた高校を生きてみなさい
怒りがあんたこういう風に生きてみなさい
と言うん
ですだから我々は
結局はほんの
が
乱れちゃって
本能の上にいくつかの
ゴミの
蓋みたいなもの現れちゃって
いわゆる割愛の上に感情という
癌が生まれてくるん
怒りやらこれ癌です増えるは増えるは
増える
例えば欲も癌ですいくらでも増える
そこでその
割愛よりも
欲と怒りが
我々に指令するん
ですだから我々はありがたく
欲と怒りが言う通りに生きているんですで
も良くて怒りが作ったのは数えと本能な
んです本能だけで生きているならば道徳は
ないん
です本能だけで生きていることは
犬猫の仕事です
もう人間になっているんです
だって動物も行かれておくでしょう
猿も怒りでおくでしょう
これで人間様と言われるつもり
そこで道徳っていうのそこを使わないで
認識を使って
判断してください
判断の仕方は学んでくださいと
だって喋る言語を学んだんだから学ぶこと
は
普通でしょう
何でも学んでからやって
服の着方も学んだでしょう
料理の仕方も学んだでしょう
だからすごいで学んでやってますよ学んで
やっているところはそれほど問題ないん
ですたまに料理が
ちょこちょこと失敗するんだけど
抱かれて人が死んじゃったとかない
でしょう
料理の出来が悪かったんだけど食べられる
しどんなことはない
例えば不幸なんか出かけなくちゃあかんだ
からなんか服を選んで例えば何か
羽織ったとしましょう見ないでそれで判断
間違ったんですねでも
服を着るべき何か
身体に
羽織るべきだと知ってます
よ一旦バスケの電車やら乗ってみたら男の
服でした
とそれで死ぬことはないでしょうちょっと
恥ずかしいなとかねアホなことやったなと
いう感じがあるかもしれませんだけど
だから
学ぶ世界ではそんなに問題ないんです
お釈迦様が道徳も
認識
判断の管轄で学びなさいという風に言って
いるんですね
と
理解
能力を使わないので生き方がひ道徳になり
ます
だから仏教から見れば
人間と他の生命にも生き方
根本的になん
ですなんかキリスト教でね人間だけ
言うような人間だけじゃなくてどんな生命
も
罪人になるん
ですそれは誰かのバカが何か言ったからで
はなくてこの科学的に
本能というものあるんだからね感情できて
いるからなんですはい
理性を生かすん
です
道徳とは感情ではなく
理性を活かして生きることです
ですからあれが好き
言って飛んで取るんじゃないん
ですそちらに入れてみるん
とって良いのか悪いのか
取ったら自分に対して
いいことあるのかないのかと
言われる判断
それの学ばなくちゃいけないんです
だから決して
本能で感情で生きてはいけないと
子供とか若い人々はかなり感情だけ
でしょう
好き嫌いだけできているでしょう
子供だから若いと可愛いとか思っている
ばっかりやってます
道徳はないん
です本能が行う判断は良い道徳になるので
理性を活かして生きることを制御します
だから本能を生かして
ちょっと生きることを制御しますこれが
道徳的な言い方です取る
得る
獲得することについて
リミットを考える
だからね我々は
命を支えるものは取りたい取りたい取り
たい取りたい感情
であのね取りまくったらダメなよう
と命を支えるためにはこれぐらい取った方
がいいやと
理性で判断しなくちゃいけない
そうすると道徳ですね私は昔から聞く
[音楽]
俗っぽい質問があります金持ちになりたい
誰だってそうだよと
金額はいくらぐらい考えている
わからない
金持ちになりたいもう頑張って仕事をして
もう事業を起こして
研究者になって開発して発明何でもいいん
ですか
でもあなた目指している金額はいくら
ぐらいですかと聞いちゃうとみんな言うの
は金ならいくらでも大丈夫でしょうと
リミット超えて自分の
管理リミット超えて金が入っちゃうとその
人は破壊するん
です食べるものと同じ食べるものは命を
生かしているでしょう
じゃあリミット超えてみて
どうなるのかと知ります
ただ聞くことが生きるために必要でしょう
じゃあリミット超えて聞いてみて
耳が壊れます
だから
理性を使って
リミットを考える
食べなくては死ぬんだけど死ぬんです生き
ていきたいんですだからこれぐらい食べる
お金がないと現代社会では生きていられ
ない
人間社会で
ねお金は生きるために
丸っきり入れないんだけど
ね人間同士ではまぁちょっと必要になって
い
てでもこれぐらいや
危ういものに対して
危険なものに対して
怒りで攻撃することをやめて
身を守ることにする人間が本当に
進化していない猿だから何で比較して攻撃
する
これでやりきれないんでしょう
例えば人が病気になるからもう金を殺し
ますと
金の方が地球をもう王様みたいに地球を
支配しています
これ殺せないん
金殺すとはならないん
ですだからあの国が気に入らないじゃあ
戦争する
この人は気に入らない
ぶん殴ると
この
攻撃して自分の命に面倒くさいことを
壊すことはできないん
です一個の命で
無数の命に対して怒りを抱いちゃう
とそれで死ぬでしょうだから
危ういものから
身を守るそれだけ
攻撃しない
簡単で言えば見える
熊が
吠えながら来ると
熊が吠えると言うんですかねもらってい
ますけどね
言ったらね
賢い
ねまぁ10分で死にますから
一番いいことは
熊をぶん殴って鉄砲で言って殺すことじゃ
ないん
です
逃げること
ですそれが道徳です
喧嘩に参加しない
逃げる
会社で同僚たちが
債務をいじめているならば
自分が参加しない
やっぱり自分も退化した猿のようにまぁ
自分も人をいじめることに
賛成しなくちゃと言っちゃうと
猿以下ですよ
だから悪いものから
逃げるん
割愛を生命は
必ず
みんなやるでしょう生きてきた生きていき
たいということはね
これ取り除くことはできんだから取り除い
たらどうなるかまだ分からないでしょう
だから
即席にお釈迦様は言うのは
柏やちょっと置いておいて下さいでしょう
それに
生命は
必ず死ぬというデータと合わせてください
私は生きていきたいでも
必ず死ぬ
それ見ておくんですそれで割愛の
コントロールが現れるん
ですこれが
道徳です
もしかする皆様
仏教の道徳だ戒律だからね
嘘をついてはいけないあかんとかね
殺生してはあかんという話してくれる
だろうと楽チンで来たでしょうね
ちょっと違います
そんなのどんなバカにもいるんだから
はいですからじゃあ道徳リスト
皆様がよく知ってそれなら知っているぞと
この
坊主に対して
議論することもできるぞと思ったでしょう
道徳リスト持って
殺生する中で言ったっても
殺生しないと生きられるんじゃないかとか
ね
嘘を投げて行ったってもこの世の中で正直
で何も言っちゃうとまずいことあるぞとか
ね議論したいと気持ちでね北かもしれませ
んだけどね
ちょっと待った方がいいん
ですじゃあ道徳リストについて考えちゃい
ましょう道徳にした2つあります一つは
即席
人を管理するために世間でできた道徳
リストがありますしかしこれは場所時代と
時間
条件などで変わり
ますもう誰だって道徳リスト作るは作るは
学校に行ったらそちらで家族リストがある
例えば学校
教育システム
管理する文部省から何とかもう
貴族リスト書いて送る
会社に行ったらそちらでまたリストがあっ
て
電車に乗ったらこれこれやらなかれとか
なんかリストがあって
飛行機に乗ってみたら
座っているならばシートベルトをつけた
まま出てくださいと言いながらシート
ベルトのサインも消すと
だからたくさんリストあるでしょう
飛行機に乗ったら
救命道具は早めリストの下にあるんだよと
あれ出て行きますけどボートに乗るならば
ちょっとしたボーテルになればみんなあれ
かけるでしょうライフ
フェイス
ボート
転覆したらしたならばこれかけてください
よだからボートに乗る前にもらう
んですまぁ大きいボートの場合は
それほど問題ないんだけど
最初は1回
猛烈なスピードで
動く
軍人の冒頭に乗ったことがあるんですね
だから
一般人のボートにあるものとまるっきり
違う中は
いいんだけど
塗る前にこれちゃんとつけてくださいと
チェックして
乗って行ったんですねやっぱりあまり
スピード
でそういう風に言いたかったのはいろんな
ところで道徳リストあるん
です場所は変わるとその道徳は
要りません
ねですから
人類交通リストはないんですね
即席では
アメリカに行ったらやるべきこととやって
はいけないことは日本ではアメリカ関係
ない風になります
ね日本でいる場合は必ずそんなこういう風
に生きるべきということは別にアフリカに
行ったらやらなくてもいいことあるん
そういうわけで福祉権が作る道徳は場所に
よって変わる時代によって変わる
条件によって変わる
人類共通の道徳リストはありません個人は
他人に管理されることになるし自立を好む
心は道徳リストに
敵意だけ
です時々例えば学校の
校則
会社の
決まり
政府が作る法律とかね結構
狂暴でしょ
あれでどうなるのかというと人を管理する
んです人の自由を奪うん
です学校に入る
子どもたちの自由がなくなっちゃうん
です
嘘を言うんで学校でみんな
元気で明るくて自由に遊んで勉強している
んだから真っ赤な嘘です
決まり決まり決まり決まり決まり
ですそうなってくるとなんか心の中で
束縛されているでしょう
自分を奴隷にし
ている
必ず回らなくちゃいけない道徳の場合は
あなたは奴隷になっているということに
なる
んです
奴隷にされるとなんかどこか
でこの法律に
敵持っちゃう
チャンスあったら破るぞ
だから
絶対高くする流れて行ってみてください
高校生
にみんなタバコ吸うことにするん
です一回
ちょっとかどうか駅で見たんだけど
[音楽]
男3人から
高校一年生ぐらいだと思いますけどタバコ
を吸う訓練しているん
ですあれは悪いと言っていたから
でしょうそこで連中にはありできないん
です吸えないんで
だから
涙が来る
鼻水が出るわもう最悪状態
でも頑張って苦労しながらタバコ
吸ってやるソフト頑張っているんですねだ
からこの社会システムだからそうなる
でしょうに
だから私はね君たちそんなに高くつい
たければタバコ
吸ってる大人に聞きなさいよ教えてあげ
たかったんですけど
ね卵の吸い方ね
そんな
スパイク出しながらねホーム
汚くなるんですよ
だからタバコ吸う大人におじさんタバコの
吸い方を教えてください頼めば
そうなってくると結果どうと思う
嫌だと断るん
ですだから人に道徳教えても教え方みんな
知らないん
です私ならタバコ吸いたいじゃあタバコ
吸っている経験者から学んでくださいよ
学ぶことそうなってくるとあの
精神
システムが働いて
ね
[音楽]
言うことを守っちゃうと自分が
奴隷になる
言うことに逆らった方がかっこいいや
とだからタバコの正しい使い方教えてあげ
たら
逆らいたくてやらないこと決めるんです
そんなもんです人間が
はい
えっととにかくそれも覚えておきましょう
嘘少ないと言った途端嘘をついた私
殺生する流れで言ったら動物
昆虫たちを殺したくなるんですね
人の物取らないと言っちゃうと取りたく
なる
んですなぜ何々する流れと言った途端生命
の自立
自由を
犯している
だから生命は攻撃する
逆に
あなた方は絶対
嘘つくなよと言ったところで行った人は
道徳を選ぶんです
理解できますか
だから私はこの馬鹿なこと言いません今日
はこの怪物を守ってくださいと言われる
だろうと期待しても言いません
はい皆様こういうわけで誤解を守って
ください言いません
どんな風に生きたって私に関係ないしねだ
から
成長する中で嘘つく中で
嫉妬する流れと言うたびに言われる側の
自由を
犯しているでしょう
だから生命の
尊厳を犯すことも非道徳なん
ですだから
宗教の道徳本読んでみて
聖書とかねまぁ偉そうになって思ったこと
ばかりでも10個も言うのは
奴隷になれ奴隷なりそれはもう嫌になる
ほどというコーラに読んでみると何時は
奴隷になる奴隷になり奴隷になるそれが
90%行って10%ぐらいこうやっては
いけないこうやってはいけないとまた道徳
言うん
見てください人の自由をこんなに壊して
いるんです人の尊厳を
壊しているん
ですあなた作ったの俺だよ
と俺の管理
以外
隠れて一切何もできませんよう
と言ったらあの生命の態の
尊厳というのこんな
壊しているん
ですだから皆様道徳やとかね思っている本
などは逆なんです
本当は
だから気持ち悪くなるのは当たり前で
宗教でうるさいなと思うのは当たり前で私
もそう思っているし
本当に気持ち悪くなるんでしょうあの自分
の
テレワークの坊主たちでもしゃべるところ
ぶん殴りたいこいつはと思うと結構あるん
です
こんな年寄りは若者元気な態度から
ぶん殴ったら自分ひどい目にあるんだから
付き合いじゃない
自由は自由は自由は人に
話しなさい
自分は道徳を犯していることに気づかない
ん
ですだから道徳を犯さず言えるのは
慈悲を実践しましょう
程度
です
慈悲を実践しましょうと言っても相手の
尊厳を
破ってないん
です
殺生する
ですからこの道徳はどうしても破りたい
ものです
世間の道徳は
まぁ守った方がいいなと
わかるんだけど破りたいん
です子供と同じでしょう
宿題やった方がいいんだけどとやりたく
ない
道徳の場合
守る方がいいに決まってますよあなたは
守りたく
ないだからすぐ世間がいろんなこの
脅し使うんです
神を信じなさい
信仰するものは救われます
と信仰しない人はいろんな地獄に落ちます
一滴道徳だから私の理論から見ればただ
信仰しないだけでお前私は永遠な地獄に
落とすならばてめぇほど悪人がないよ
私は仏教だからそういう反論するんです
世の中でテミーほど悪人がいないんだよ
とでは皆様にそんな
言葉考えないでしょう皆様ご丁寧に生きて
いるんだから
ね私みたいに品のない生き方していない
でしょう
結局は動物に飼われている猿以外何でも
ないでしょう
信仰それから
儀式
ねあれは習慣だよ習慣だよとか
儀式儀礼などの枠に入れて人々に無理やり
道徳
守ってもらうもらいたいという大変な苦労
です
よ頭痛の種なんです人間に道徳も持って
もらうために
こちら入れてないんだけど道徳世界でも雨
と無知の理念必ず使ってますよこれこれ
守れば天国に行きますよこれ
破っちゃえば地獄に落ちますよとか
雨と餅を出して言う言葉は道徳じゃないん
です
そういう道徳守ってみても人格向上はし
ないなぜならば真面目に学べれば守るほど
奴隷制が強くなるだけ
自立がなくなるんです自分の足で立つ力が
減るん
ですだから人格向上のチャンスがないん
ですしかし
断言悪くないよ社会との調和
トラベルを起こさず
なんとなく生きられるだけ
はい7に行きます
仏教にも残念ながら道徳リストあるん
です
命の書記仕組みを知り尽くす
までは時間かかります
お釈迦様言うのは命のシステムを神速して
ください
そうすると命のコンロを自分にできるん
ですでもこれちょっと時間かかります
この間
道徳的な生き方をすると人は自己破壊に
陥ります
あなたの命の仕組みを勉強するまでいいよ
と好き勝手に来たとその人は道徳破っ
ちゃうと自分の人生が
破壊するでしょう
だから
人格
完成と知恵を完成したブッダが簡単な道徳
リストを解かれたんですまぁとりあえず今
分からなくてもこの
リストを守ってくださいとなぜ
守るべきかということは
命は
命の行政仕組みを自分自身でやって
くださいそこまで時間かかるんだから
そこは
どんな大丈夫
仏教
症状仏教
原子仏教
寺エラーで仏教どんな仏教でも
これ
捨てられなくなっちゃったんです
ブッダに逆らうことはすごい自慢する
代表の世界でも
なんかどうにもならなく仏陀っていうのは
すごい賢いなと思った
優先順位アップという10回やるん
ですそこでラジオのお坊様方はねもう
私たちに悪口言いながら
帰りを守ることはすごい品がないという風
に言われたことあるんです
でも自分たちは儀式だけで重点重役を
唱えるん
です
唱え方ちょっと会ってないんだけどね
動詞が何時はこれ
守るやーか田舎とか聞くだけでね自分で
言わなくちゃあかんだけど
とにかく
優先順位はこのリストを皆様
各自で調べてみてください
これだけで道徳すべてです
10項目です
なら私は今でも言えますけどね一応
パートナー
あれ3番目は2つありますね最近は
カーネーション
守るべき全ての道徳が
含まれていますそれ以上も以下もありませ
ん
それ守れば道徳
完璧
戒律というリストもありますが共通なのは
誤解だけですそこであの
聖典では
分厚い本一つあるんです
規模細かいんですよ私も全部読んでないん
です
途中で嫌になって
面倒くさいと止めるんですけどねそれ
ぐらいありますよでもあれはみんな守る
必要はないんです
戒律と必要ならば誰だって5回ぐらいは
守って欲しいということになるんです
でも道徳としては10回です
仏教との最低
乖離率出家戒律もあります数は複数です
ブッダの道徳リストは
普遍的で社会と時代によって変える必要は
ない
社会が変わったからと言って
ブッダの道徳はいつでも有効な守らなく
ちゃいけない有効なんです
携帯あるから開けて嘘ついて言うわけじゃ
ないんです
携帯でしてSNSでも
嘘する部分だよ
と日本でSNSと言うんだから
ピッチャーで
鍛え上げ
嘘を打つなよ
休憩しますか
ちょっと10分ぐらいとにかく集計した方
がいいん
ですそれでは夜まで
休憩いたしますので
よろしくお願いします
4時から再開いたします
[音楽]
確かに
大丈夫です
では始まります
この8
章で
道徳コードを守るのかと
道徳って何ですかと言ったら10cm枠を
調べてくださいあの普通の
仏教でもどちらでもあります
どうやって守るのかと
儀式
習慣として守ることもできます
そこでここでも公園始まる前になんか
ちょっと
儀式
っぽいというかねそういう風にまぁ戒律を
受けたんだからじゃあどうしようもない
仕方がなく守るこれもできます
しかし
儀式として守ると一説になったり
感情に負けて
破ったりもし
意味を理解して自己責任で守ることをし
ますですから
道徳っていうのはちゃんと学校
仏教学校で学んでほしい
それはどんなバカにもできるものじゃなく
てちゃんと知識ある律やる人はこういう
わけでこの肛門をこういうわけでこの項目
で学ぶと
まぁ例えばねあの
体のことやらね学ぶとビジネスの働きやら
こんな風にビジネス感染しますよとかね
学んだ人は大体自分を身を守るでしょう
自然
だから知った方がよろしいですね
守りなさいとブッダが指令しない
どこにもないん
です自分の悪感情を制御して全感情を
育てる目的で
守る道徳は人格向上と
解脱に人を導きます
お釈迦様がブッダだから
リスト教えてます
よ守りなさい
勉強すれば
自分でやっぱり守った方がいいなと
一人一人が思うん
ですそういうわけで
戒律にはレベル2つあるんです一つは
儀式として
項目を
暗記して
守る
仏教徒だからじゃあ誤解は守りますよとか
ねとか
何とかとか言ってまぁこの子の帰りを守る
となんとなく
儀式っぽいですね
その
レベルもう一つ
存在欲活発はよ混同して感情コントロール
して
感情に負けないで
理性で生きるために
頑張りました
あるいは別れすれば
欲にかつ欲に負けないために
これこれこれ例えば食事コントロールする
苦しいでしょうに食いたいか人にとっては
ではなくて自分のこの性格だらしない
自分がどうしても味に負けてしまう
豚みたいな人間や
とだからこれ何とか直そう
と思って自分が食事コントロールする
レベル高いでしょう
何であんたこのおいしいものあるのに食べ
ないのかもったいないでしょう
と言ってもね私は結構ですこれしか食べ
ません
いくらがかっこいいんですね
欲に負けません
怒りに負けません
人に悪口言われて言われても人を怒鳴ら
ないいわゆる
悪口
言わない
自分が弱いからじゃないん
です
怒りが出てくるとすごく言いたくなるん
怒りを
怒りの感情の混同すると言って言葉をそれ
一番かっこいいん
ですだからシイラとアジシイラという
ステージ二つ道徳にあります
消えるくらいは大体仏教以外にもあります
宗教と関係なく普通の社会にもあります
恥知らは仏教なんです
はい9番目に行きます
ちょっと別なポイント生きる免許という
テーマにしたんです
免許取ってよ
生まれて生命は死ぬまで生きるん
です本当にすごいんですね死ぬまで行けれ
ば生きられるんだから
しかし正しい生き方は知らない
収入を得るために
教育を受けますが
正しく生きるための
教育を
嫌がられ
ます本当におかしいんですよ
収入るために学校中中小中高大学に入っ
ちゃうしねそれからいろんな研究所やられ
たら外国で留学までしたり
あるいは会社でいろんな
訓練を受けたり
一個が結構頑張ってます
よでも生きて生きているからでしょう
そんなのはやっているの
は生きていること仕事より大事でしょう
生きていることは
結婚することよりも大事でしょう
生きていることはマイホーム作ることより
も大事でしょ
何で生きることは学ばないんですか
命の仕組みを学んで自分にも他人にも幸福
をもたらす
概要を与えない生き方を学んで生きる免許
習得した方が良い
ですそこで仏教学校というのは
ブッダの教え離ることですこの仏教学校で
これ大学よりもレベル高いんです
生きる免許を上げるんです
そこで道徳あの私はちょっと
慌ててこれ書いたんだから
忘れたポイントがありまして道徳っていう
のはいろんな方法でまとめているんですよ
一番わかりやすいのは自分が幸せになる
自分の親しい周りが
幸せになる一般的に生命がみんな幸せに
なる生き方が道徳的なやり方
ですそこで自分に
害を与える周りに害を与える生命一般的に
害を与える自然生命全て
に害を与える不幸になる生き方は
断言希望と
かですそれだけ自己判断で生きてみれば
それだけで行徳すべて終わりでしょう
至って簡単
でしょうGoodForMeGood
Foradidas
formegoodforth
andgoodforeverygood
と言い方してくださいよ
そんな風に言える人間物体がいますもう一
つ道徳を
[音楽]
判断する
方法あります
貪瞋痴を拡大させる生き方がひどい
トンデンジンを
なくさなくてもちょっと制御する生き方が
善行に
ですから
隣人に逆らう行為も
善光堂々
例えば何か自分のために取ることの場合は
欲が働きます
ねだから取ったことはご飯とったらすごい
ですかとそれじゃないんです
漁師知っているならば
ね弁当重ねてありますねみんなの自分が
この弁当二つ食べられますからとかね結構
見たらたくさんありますよ
と人々食べる人々は住人がいて
弁当13枚
巻いてるんですか
13個もあります二つ食べて悪くないと二
つ取っちゃうとか
ねまあだからまあ
しかし
ご飯取って食べることは
欲ですけど悪行為にならないそれを知って
いる
命を支える
そこを潰しちゃうと悪行為になる
ですから
貪瞋痴を制御する生き方は
道徳
で
貪瞋痴をかき立てる生き方は
ということになりますで逆に例えば何で
布施することやら慈悲の瞑想することやら
ね普通の瞑想することは最高な時やと言っ
てますかと言うとすることでやっぱり
欲を
欲に
反対の
精神が生まれるん
ですやめて横が死ぬんです
だから
道徳になるんで瞑想する時
慈悲の瞑想する時でも
貪瞋痴が何か感情が悪くて
弱くなるんです
はいそういう風にも道徳
判断することはできますね二つですね
グループホームで
という方法と
貪瞋痴
制御する生き方道徳で
貪瞋痴をかき立てる生き方は
非道徳でそれで道徳は全て終わりという
ことになるんです
まぁそういうことで
宗教世界では
宗教でなくても日本の社会でも
我々の洗脳するんですよ
脅すんです
脅して法律守ってもらうん
ですで
仏教を学んだ人々は洗脳もなく脅しもなく
生きる
免許取るんです何のこと
大体寝ていても悪い夢見ませんよ仏教の
人々は
時々夢で
罪を犯す場合やるでしょう
それもなくなります
夢で人となる
夢で人をぶん殴るとかあり得るでしょう
それもなくなります
夢で
さえ悪行為しない道徳守ると
いう夢で採掘をつかないと
簡単でしょうそんなに変な話じゃないん
ですはい次行きます
樹海の樹海に
命の仕組み
たくさんの命が集まって人の命は構成し
ます
こちらたくさん命がありますよ
無数にあるんです命は
この
身体が私だけのものじゃないんです
もう数えられないぐらい重さで見たっても
何キロもいるんで他の生命は
一個一個の細胞の中にも他の生命が入って
ます
ミトコンドリアやっている
だから
仏教の免許取ってる人は決して私の体で
言わないん
私たち皆のから
微生物の体でもあります
微生物も住んでいるところです
結局
私のものではありませんねだから
細胞1個取ってこれ俺のさ言えないよ
あのねこれ私は住んでいるところですけど
私がいなかったらこの細胞知りましょう
だから細胞怒ってあげたミトコンドリアが
私の最後まで言ったらしょうがない
でしょうに
実際そうだからそうすると細胞は全部自分
のものでなくなっちゃうん
ですからお釈迦様簡単にね私のものは何も
ないよと
言ったらみんなブッダはバカにしようと
思っているでしょう
仏陀は馬鹿な仕事して自分が馬鹿になる
だけ
ないんで
仏教科学的に見ても私の細胞は1個もない
んです
はい
認識の流れに
考えたりするで
ちょっと今日は寒いなぁと
春なのにちょっとどういう風に考える
でしょう
ある意味私とみんなラベルになっているん
です指に対して私の夢
私はどこ行ったらこの
四六時中やっている妄想に私で言ってるん
です
だからなんかおかしいでしょう
妄想が私であると
しかし
じゃあ思考は私だったら自分
思うままに思考できる
でしょう残念ながらできないね思考が
感情の
オスに入っているだから
薄で回されて回したり何の感じもないでき
ない
船で海に入ったんだけど
船にはエンジンがあるんだけど
なんか
嘘入っちゃった
竜巻に入ってしまったと知ったことじゃ
ない全部制御不可能になるでしょう
だから私
だと自分の思考に行っても
困窮できない
自分に立ち去ることもできないものをどう
やって自分のものですか
それから外にある生命システムの
もう一つ外にある生命システム
の協力なしには生きられませ
ん
身体の中にも
40兆の細胞の中にまた
命が
そこで強力で生きているんです
それで終わらない外にある生命の協力も
必要です
だから単独
我が命なんかはないんです
道徳っていうのは
皆と調和して
仲良く生きることです
出ないとあなたは
滑ります
それで私はこの指揮者という言葉使ったん
ですよだから自分で考えるでしょう考える
ことが嘘に入っているでしょう
だから今度はできない
そこで考えることに思考を入れて
瞑想でもして
妄想コントロールして
正しく考えることになると全てをしっかり
コントロールする指導する指揮者になるん
です自分の心は
そうすると全ての生命たちが一緒に
素晴らしいオーケストラで演奏します
生きると
今はみんなバラバラ
足の細胞は足の勝手で私の体の場合も心臓
の細胞は自分勝手でバラバラでやっている
んだから結構大変です
よちょっと早く歩いちゃうと死んで
ます
か
あれは老衰だから別にそれは別に道徳と
関係ないんだけどねまぁとにかく美しい
演奏っていうの
は楽器たくさんになって
ねみんなちゃんと
合わせて演奏することですねそれには指揮
者が必要です
指揮者
今指揮者がないんですだから勝手に道徳で
はないの道徳っていうのは
命に
心を知った指揮者として
育てることです
で
10で全部道徳
授業は終わりますこれは功徳
道徳って何でありがたいかとね言わなく
たってもうね生きる勉強でしょうに
免許取って何が悪いかと聞く人がいるん
ですか
ねじゃあ車で無免許で運転してみて
ください
常識でしょう道徳
は
で心と体が落ち着きます
だって指揮者がいるでしょう
楽器は誰か勝手に淫らに
演奏しません
必要な時必要な瞬間だけ音を立ててまた
黙って
良い生き方が現れますよそうすると
すっごく落ち着くん
です落ち着いたければ道徳です
病弱にならない
業によって生まれつきいろいろ
病気持って生まれたっても道徳守るとなん
となく管理できますよ
だいたいそんな人ってすごい少ないんだ
けど
病弱にならないみんな元気にいられます
理性が現れますバカではなくすごい理性的
な人間になります頭が良くなります勉強は
できるわ物事を理解できるは新しいもので
は学ぶことはできるわもういいとこ住め
でしょう
社会と対立がなく平和で
楽しく生きられます今皆様会社に行っ
たってもたいです家に行ったってもまた
そこで対立
どこでも体質的に言い方ではなくてすごく
平和でいられます
平和でいること楽しいんです
精神的な
病気が起きない
結構いるでしょう
精神的な病気の人々は
道徳を持ったら小さい時から道徳守って
欲しい
どんな
精神病にもかからない
人格が向上します
集中力が強くなりますすごい集中力が
生まれてきます
知恵が現れて解脱に達します
だから
仏像のためには道徳からどうしても
イスラールしなくちゃいけないだから
ブッダが語った道徳とはそういう
科学ですじゃあ行きます
孤独まだありますね
信頼される人間になります
他人が自分の言うことに
常に賛成します
だから生きやすいよ自分が道徳守っている
人だったら自分が何か言ったらみんなそう
ですかすぐ
賛成します
対立しない
リーダーシップのある人間になります
人の前で決して不安にならない
緊張しない
人間だけではなく他の生命にも
好かれます
幸福な生き方と
幸福な死後
確保できます
幸福に生きる
死後も幸福
死の恐怖感がなくなりますそれすごい大事
でしょうみんな知るのは怖いでしょう道徳
太ったら死の恐怖感が消え
ます解脱に達する道を歩むことになります
はいだいたい功徳はそんなもん
ですはいラストテスト
ブッダの道徳は人を脅して自由を奪う指令
ではない
人に
幸福自由安穏を与える知恵に基づいた
科学です
話は以上です
はいありがとうございました
ちょうど時間が
16時27分ですので
限定お一人ぐらいで何かご質問あれば
受け付けましたいかがでしょうか
皆さん疑問が
人いらっしゃいました
チャプター8の最後のところにシーラーと
アリシーラっていうシイラとアジシイラル
という言葉があったんですけどもアディ
シーラっていうのは
マッカーシーガとパラシーラーのこと
でしょうか
チャプター8の最後にシイラと
いう言葉があったんですけども
マハーサードの本に
パーソナリティとあと古い
マッカーシーラーと
パラシーラっていう言葉があったんです
けどそれと関係があります
何言ってるかわからない
寂しいというのは
難しいだと
パラシーラのことですか
[音楽]
伝統的に繰り返して暗記して言っている
ものでミャンマーのお坊さんてもう
ちょっと理解して欲しいと思いますよ
鵡返しばかりするんだから
そんなものはないよ
[音楽]
全くおかしいん
ですこれはだけはもうはっきりと
文句言わなくちゃあかんです真っ赤って
いうのはもう
修行に入って
解脱するのに対する道でしょうねパラって
いうのは解脱に
達したことでしょうに
解脱に達した人に
戒律関係ないでしょうに
それってあのテーラワーが
純テールワードの説明です
順テールバーでは
純ブッダの教えとはぴったりはめません
結構脱線したところ考えるんですだから
シーラーアビスイルとは例えば
嘘をつかない
嘘少ないのは
人格向上するために感情悪感情を抑える
ために
自分時の戒めのために自分の
成長を考えて
チェックしながら
嘘をつかないことは激しいの
ですだからちょっと
品が上ということです
激しい
という風に経典にありますけどねこれは
もうテレワークで注釈書に入っちゃうと
もうハチャメチャおかしい
縮尺になります
という言葉もありますよアビダンまって
いうのはその場合は7つのテキストじゃ
ないん
ですブッダが浴びたまという言葉を使うと
ねまあそういうことで関係ない皆様にはい
終わりはいありがとうございますでは最後
に
祈願の門を
皆さんたいと思います
はいみなさんご一緒に食べましょう
ね
[音楽]
苦しんで
悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく一切の生命
が安穏でありますように
サルサルサルはいありがとうございます
[拍手]
ありがとうございましたそれから皆様ご
清聴ありがとうございました今日ちょっと
あの
質疑
応答の時間あまり取れなかったのですが
この後ですね午後
8時
ズームの方で
振り返りの
ズーム交流会1時間ほど予定しております
ので
ぜひそちらのご参加ください
今日のYouTubeのライブ
配信の
動画の概要欄に
ZOOMのリンクが掲載されておりますの
でそちらの方から
リンクをクリックしてお入りいただければ
と思いますそれから結構
忘れ物など
[音楽]
ちょこちょこございますので
お帰りの際には足元あとお席の間とかです
ね
一度確認してから帰りくださいそれから
今日は雨なので
傘のお忘れ物が
必ず出るんじゃないかと思い
ます
お手元の傘
忘れないようにもう一度ご確認の絵を書い
てください足元も滑りやすくなっており
ますので
気をつけて
迎えくださいそれはどうもありがとう
ございました